[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Clea and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today today's topic will be
about the influence of Technology on
your education during High School the
impact of technology on high school
education is nothing short or
revolutionary it has transformed the way
we teach and learn from interactive
whiteboards to the myriads of
personalized learning apps and sources
at our fingertips in this episode we'll
dissect how technology has influenced
the high school experience over the past
years few years and what it means for
students and Educators
alike the way high school education is
conducted today is different from what
most of us think instead of imposing
heavy textbooks and covering blackboards
with chalk classrooms are em embracing
technology which allows students to
learn more Dynamic and individualized
ways ebooks and digital resources are
also becoming more prevalent there are
two sides to every coin the integrating
technology into high school education is
no exception as with any significant
change it brings both benefits and
challenges to begin with let's talk
about some of the benefits there is no
doubt that technology has changed the
way we learn this makes lesson More
engaging and interactive capturing the
attention of digital natives who have
grown up surrounded by screens and have
grown up with them as part of their
environment students are now able to
collaborate with colleagues from across
the world on project and sh share ideas
with colleagues across the classroom
transcending the boundaries of
conventional classroom
walls despite this challenges continue
to remain students today spent a
considerable amount of time in front of
screens and the consequences of
prolonged screen time are a matter of
concern the physical and psychological
effects on of this
ship needs to be examined closely
additionally not all students have
equally access to technology the digital
divide is a pressing issue that
Educators and policy makers must address
to ensure that no students is Left
Behind one of the most exciting
developments in high school education is
the concept of personalized learning
technology is at the heart of this
transformation in a world where everyone
learns at their own pace adaptive
learning software and learning
management system have become become
essential
tools these systems Empower Educators to
tailor lessons to each student's unique
learning style and Pace it's a genuinely
student- centered approach promoting a
deeper understanding of subject and
increased knowledge
retention the influence of Technology
isn't just about making high schools
education more convenient it's about
preparing students for a future that is
undergoing constant change in the
digital age students are acquiring
skills Beyond using
technology they're learning how to think
critically solve complex problems and
adapt to world that in a that's in a
state of Perpetual flux as an example of
this is Comm
communicational communication skills
have also evolved high school students
today often engage in Virtual
presentations and video conferences this
this prepares them for a job market
where remote work and digital
Communications are increasingly common
students learn how to articulate their
ideas effectively and engage in Virtual
teamwork technology has R re redefined
the Dynamics between the teachers and
students no longer is the teacher the
only source of information High School
Educators have become facilitators and
guides to the
students learning Journeys this shift in
Dynamic encourages open dialogue and
collaboration students have more
opportunities to voice their opinions
and engage in discussion creating a more
inclusive and
interactive classroom environment here's
an example in a class in a science class
instead of Simply memorizing facts
students can use technology to conduct
virtual experiments they can simulate
chem chemical reactions in a Virtual Lab
observe the outcomes and draw their
conclusions the teachers's role shifts
from dictating experiments through
helping students understand the
scientific method and Its Real World
applications as another example is a
traditional history class a history
teacher might have lectured on a
specific historical event with
technology the same teacher can now
assign students to research various
perspective on that
event and then lead a class discussion
where students present and defend their
findings the teacher becomes a facilit
facilitator of critical thinking guiding
the discussion rather than being the
sole
expert as we navigate this era of
digital transformation in high school
education it's important to remember
that technology is a tool that empowers
students when using thoughtfully as an
enabler of personalized learning and a
bridge to a future filled with digital
opportunities but as we Embrace these
changes let's also remember to maintain
a balance with real world experiences
and human
connections thank you so much for
joining us on this episode of high
school memories it's been an incredible
journey and we're so glad you came along
for the ride until next time take
care
[Music]